-Thank you so much
for coming back to the show,
and thanks for playing
"Random Instrument Challenge."
-That was wild!
-Yeah. You know what's crazier?
So, during the break, you told
one of our segment producers
that you actually know
how to play
one of the weird instruments
we had there.
-Yeah, about as well
as I played the sousaphone
and the upright bass.
-No, but I was in shock.
I go, "Wait. This is --
We have to --"
I want to see you play this,
because I know
kind of the idea behind it.
This is a theremin.
-Yeah.
So, this is pitch.
[ Theremin plays ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
Wow! Maggie Gyllenhaal!
I mean, that is --
that is a talent right there.
-Yeah, this is, like,
the extent of my musical talent.
-I love that.
Well, last time you were here,
speaking of talents,
we were talking about
"The Lost Daughter," but how
you adapted it from this book
that you read by the same name.
-Mm-hmm.
-You've already won
and been nominated
for all these awards,
and I think totally deserved.
It was a beautiful movie.
It was gorgeous.
In fact,
at Venice Film Festival,
that's where, I think,
we first heard about it.
It got like a 20-minute
standing ovation or something.
Crazy. Were you nervous even
just going into the festival?
-Yeah, I mean, look,
we made the film in a pandemic.
But more than that,
we cut it in a pandemic,
before there were
any vaccines or anything.
I was cutting
this time last year.
And so we never showed it
to an audience, ever.
Which, if you don't make films,
I don't know,
it may be hard to know
how strange that is.
But, usually, you invite
your friends and family,
you invite, you know --
-Screen it and --
-Then you screen it,
and you find out how it plays,
and you hear people laugh,
and then people give you notes,
and you adjust the film
sometimes based on those notes.
Here it was just
me and my editor.
I mean,
we showed to it a few people,
but they were people
who already loved us.
You know? They were --
-Yeah, it's like my mom
going like, "Jimmy,
you were the greatest person
ever to be on
'Saturday Night Live.'"
I go, "Oh, my God.
What a great review, Mom."
-Exactly.
-"Thanks."
And so the first time
I ever saw my film
with any audience --
like, I'm talking anything --
was at Venice.
And the Grande Sala
with hundreds of people
and Olivia Colman
and Dakota were there --
Dakota Johnson -- and they had
never seen the movie at all.
Sitting next to me
at the Venice Film Festival
was the first time.
-How do you set it up,
and how do you talk about
what the movie's about?
-Well, it's about a woman
who goes on vacation alone,
and while she's on vacation,
she gets really compelled
by this young mother
that she sees on the beach,
and it starts bringing up
for her all of these
wild, dark, strange memories
in her own life
that start
to really trip her out.
-Because she was a young mother,
and...
I don't want to spoil anything,
but, uh...
-She was a young mother
who struggled
with being a mother, like,
if we're honest,
I think every mother
who ever existed.
-Yeah.
-But, you know, I think
we're used to either seeing
a sort of fantasy version
of the mother
that we all wished we had
or the mother
that we wished we were,
or, like, a bad mommy.
You know?
And the thing that that does is,
it makes you go like,
"Oh, look at that
crazy, bad mommy.
I'm nothing like that.
Thank God.
You know, I'm such a good mama."
But to join them together,
which is what this movie does,
you know, where it's
complicated, you know?
-But it's so well done and shot
and directed and written.
And you wrote
and directed this, buddy.
And I will say this --
last time you were here,
we were talking about this.
You were thinking about
optioning.
And I go, "Why is it --
Why are you waiting this long
to direct?"
Do you remember
what you said to me?
-I think I said, um...
that it took me a long time
to even allow myself
to feel how much
I wanted to do it,
that I didn't feel entitled
to even think about it.
-Now that you did it,
do you feel great
that you're on the other side
and you now have a movie
under your belt
that's fantastic?
-I feel like...
I love acting,
and I miss acting,
but I was always, like,
bumping up against something --
you know? --
about what I wanted to say
or express or do or offer.
And it was like --
I don't even know
how to explain it.
It was like --
Do you ever have a dream that --
It's like a common dream I think
people have where they're,
like, in their little apartment
and they dream that
they open a door,
and all of a sudden,
there's an entire other wing?
You know?
And you're like --
You've had that dream.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
I had a dream that I was getting
chased by a shark last night.
[ Laughter ]
-But you've never
had that dream?
This is what it was like.
It was like, all of a sudden,
I just knocked a wall down,
and I was like,
"It's so much better over here."
-Yeah.
-Because I do think,
when women make movies,
and women do a lot of things
and really express themselves,
it looks different.
And something new and different
is really compelling, you know?
And honest.
-I appreciate you being honest
even when we talked about
before you did this
and you were like,
"I don't know if I even know."
Couldn't even talk about it,
even directing it, I think,
to now, you did it,
and it's a homer.
Honestly, it's moving,
it's beautiful, it's fantastic.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek
at "The Lost Daughter."
Take a look.
-[ Breathing heavily ]
She's driving me crazy.
'Cause Daddy's away, right?
Daddy's away,
and you're taking it out on me.
-All right.
Come to auntie, baby.
Come on, come to auntie.
There we go, my big girl.
Oh, boy!
My big girl.
-Go, so I can have a minute.
Sometimes I just
can't handle it.
-I know.
-Okay?
Yes, anything you want.
Show Mama -- Show Mama and the
lady what a good girl you are.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Maggie Gyllenhaal, everybody.
"The Lost Daughter"
is in select theaters
and streaming now on Netflix.